welcome back to the David Pacman show
I'm producer Pat Ford filling in for
David today while he's away some pretty
big news broke yesterday which is that
Hunter Biden the son of President Joe
Biden has reached a tentative agreement
with Federal prosecutors to plead guilty
to two minor tax charges and to admit to
the facts of a gun charge the plea deal
will likely keep Hunter Biden out of
jail and it's subject to approval by a
federal judge which is likely going to
happen the proposed deal includes
pleading guilty to two misdemeanor tax
charges for failures to pay taxes in
2017 and 2018 with a combined liability
of approximately 1.2 million dollars
prosecutors are going to recommend
probation for the tax charges and then
the gun charge is going to be handled as
a diversion case where Hunter will be
able to technically not have to plead
guilty to the crime and he'll be able to
do so if he successfully meets the
measures outlined in the diversion
program the gun charge will ultimately
likely be removed from his record so
Hunter Biden's gun charge stems from a
false statement that he made on
paperwork while he was purchasing a gun
he denied drug use or having a drug
problem when in fact that wasn't true
lying on gun purchase forms is only a
small percentage of firearm related
prosecutions and typically it's tacked
on as a secondary offense and that seems
to be what happened here Hunter Biden's
lawyer stated that he takes
responsibility for the tax mistakes made
during a period of turmoil and addiction
in his life the full statement from his
lawyer Chris Clark was quote Hunter will
take responsibility for two instances of
failure to file tax payments when due
a firearm charge which will be subject
to a pre-trial diversion agreement and
will not be the subject of the plea
agreement will also be filed by the
government I know Hunter believes it is
important to take responsibility for
these mistakes he made during a period
of turmoil and addiction in his life he
looks forward to continuing his recovery
and moving forward the White House for
its part has expressed support for
Hunter Biden stating that the president
and the first lady love their son and
support his efforts to rebuild his life
so I hear all this information and I
think that all right it looks like
justice has been served Hunter Biden
clearly did some stuff wrong and he
appears to have committed some crimes
here he didn't pay taxes that he owed to
the federal government that effectively
is stealing from the rest of us and so
he should have to pay his fair share
just like anybody else he did lie while
going through the process of obtaining a
weapon and you can't say that you're not
using drugs when going through that
process when you actually are at the
time you may disagree about whether that
should be illegal or not but the law
says that it is currently and so sure he
should be held accountable for it and I
think that the correct agreement was
ultimately reached here he takes the
plea deal he gets a slap on the wrist
with the probation he doesn't have to go
to jail or anything like that it doesn't
seem to me like these amount to jail
worthy crimes anyway we can end it now
right this is really not all that hard
and I don't look at this case and think
oh I have to defend Hunter Biden at all
costs I really don't care about Hunter
Biden right I apply the same standard
when it comes to anyone facing criminal
charges right whether it's Trump whether
it's Biden Hillary whoever if there's
something to investigate you should
investigate if there's something to
charge then you should charge if it can
be proven in court then go ahead and
prove it and ultimately if a sentence is
warranted whether that be sending
someone to prison or otherwise then
sentence them appropriately but with the
Maga folks they pretend as though Hunter
Biden this whole time has been like Al
Capone or Charles Manson when in reality
these are pretty minor charges and at
the same time they defends Donald Trump
no matter what
when he's accused of keeping the
nation's top secrets in his bathroom at
Mar-A-Lago that anyone can just stumble
upon if they knew their way around the
resort and he of course refused to give
the documents back after months and
months of the National Archives asking
and that's just one of the multiple
criminal investigations now criminal
prosecutions that Donald Trump is
dealing with also relevant to this is
the fact that Donald Trump was actually
president and wants to be president
again whereas Hunter Biden I hate to
break it to you but he's actually not
the president he just so happens to be
related to the current president he is
the son of the president but that
doesn't mean that he is the president he
doesn't even work in his father's
Administration we've of course discussed
this ad nauseum but I suppose the
question now is how is the Republican
party going to react to the news of
Hunter Biden taking this plea deal
because they can do a couple of things
right they can either act triumphant and
say look he's technically pleaded guilty
so it proves that the Biden crime family
narrative we've been pushing this entire
time is true it shows how Joe Biden by
extension is unfit to be president or
something like that
or on the other hand they could take the
approach of saying look how the
prosecutors in this case treated Hunter
Biden with kid gloves and they let him
go free not sending him to jail even
though this is a very standard plea deal
and Trump has had plenty of
opportunities to cooperate with
investigators and it will probably be
offered plea deals as well I just don't
think he's going to take them so in
reality the right-wing media is probably
going to do a mix of both when talking
about this hunter story depending on
whatever serves them best at the time
but I do believe ultimately this is the
best outcome for this case
one of our sponsors today is replace
your mortgage mortgages are a really
interesting thing in the United States
the poor often can't afford them and the
rich often don't use them instead the
wealthy use special Financial tools to
pay off their debts often in a fraction
of the time that it takes for a middle
class American to realize that same
payoff replace your mortgage teaches you
how you can pay off your home in five to
seven years without needing to make more
money than you're currently making right
now and in addition they can teach you
how to better utilize your existing
assets and Equity to beginner continue
growing wealth and passive income
through additional strategies and they
actually have an upcoming Workshop that
will show you how you can take advantage
of these strategies how it all works
create your own economy in a sense you
can go to replace your universe city.com
slash Pacman to watch the interview I
did with their founder Michael Lush to
learn how you can get exclusive access
to what can be a life-changing virtual
event the link is in the description